remember your arduous Redfield's
professional actor traveling to Venus to
audition for the part of for hundreds of
maskavich now you are summoned by
personal invitation so security should
be minimal
break a leg
what was going through your head when
you said let's go to Venus and then have
Hitler they're like and you can't kill
him if you want to but it'll end the
game right well your condition in the
face yeah and you can kick him both from
the front and from the back oh no these
are things you have to like figure out
when you're doing this shoot list of the
animations like alright but what if the
player walks around him okay so a lot of
it is simulating how it would be inside
your own hand playing the game when you
just have text right and so all the time
you have to think about like okay but as
a player you're now because you most of
the seniors sitting in the chair but
then you stand up and Hitler's right
there so I'm sure a lot of people would
like why not try and kick him in the
face you know yeah
so we whenever whenever we detect that
such an impulse could occur then we try
to make a game supported you know but
yeah that was an amazingly fun scene to
ride and record and we had these
tremendous actors who just came in and
killed it so so we were thinking about
like how do we get there we really love
the idea of him sort of trying to escape
the terrorist threats on on Earth and
Venus
is he company movida let me see a shaft
spins so we started building the scene
oh we thought it would be really fun if
the player and BJ was auditioning for
the part of himself and and it's not
doing a good job of it and you are a
Nazi [ __ ] that scene was so it was
funny it was also like tense right it
was yeah yeah no he's scary too it's
very unhinged which and and we have this
we conceptualized him because we're
trying to find some sort of character
trait for all of our characters that we
can sort of ground them in and for
Hitler way we thought like what if he as
a personality is like the opposite of
spiritual everything with him is very
physical so it has a lot of sort of
physical activities yeah loved worth
Damelin he's like I'm tired now if you
take over please don't notice how are ya
yeah he just lays down I was watching I
was like what's he doing that body's
like at least leave the room no no yeah
because that's like somebody has so much
power and have had it for so long that
they just don't care like it doesn't
matter what they do
nobody's gonna question them anyway any
room there it is like their domain yeah
[Music]